ich liebe weihnachten wie kann man
weihnachten nicht leben
ich mag die magie die rituale die
lichter alles schenken sich die falschen
geschenke
aber das ist okay geschenk für mich
das ist nicht ihr ernst
lori penny nennt sich selber gern ein
schräger hippie ein nerd seit jahren
kämpft die oxford absolventin für ihre
feministischen anliegen darum mit ganz
allem rund um weihnachten ist sie dann
doch nicht einverstanden mit der
geschichte der jungfräulichen maria sie
muss die ganze schwangerschaft
durchmachen das ganze drama die
körperlichen beschwerden
und das alles ganz ohne sex den besten
teil von allem was soll das die braucht
mir spaß und schon sind wir mitten in
paddys kernthema die selbstbestimmung
der frau der kampf gegen körperliche und
ökonomische ausbeutung dazu verhält sie
sich laut und geistreich sie twittert
bloggt schreibt kolumnen essays und
reportagen
ihr ton ist wütend und doch voller
schalk gespickt mit persönlichen
anekdoten
[Musik]
penny ist ein punk mit hellwachen geist
eine sozialistische feministin
[Musik]
traditionelle frauenarbeit von der
schwangerschaft über kindererziehung und
hausarbeit wird in der gesellschaft
nicht als arbeit anerkannt
erst dann wenn frauen die ärmer sind oft
farbige frauen aber immer frauen bezahlt
werden diese arbeit für andere zu
übernehmen
die forderung dieser arbeit als arbeit
zu betrachten ist ein zentraler teil
meines für minus von frauen und ihre
arbeit erzählt penny auch in ihrem neuen
buch babys machen
es sind science-fiction-geschichten
ungemütliche zukunftsfantasien weniger
elektrisierend zwar als ihre
gesellschaftskritischen texte doch für
penny nicht minder politisch sich die
zukunft vorzustellen ist per se ein
politischer akt damals dir eine andere
zukunft aus basierend auf dem was du
bist und was deine ansichten sind sie
distanziert sich vom elitären mainstream
feminismus will einen feminismus für
alle
[Musik]
es geht um die befreiung der frau vor
man ja aber auch um die befreiung aller
von patriarchalen kapitalismus freiheit
für alle
nicht weniger als eine geschlechter
revolution strebt penny an
für echte gleichstellung da ist sie
radikal ich selber identifiziere mich
nicht ganz als frau und auch nicht als
mann
ich habe ein anderes geschlecht eines in
der mitte von lori heißt eigentlich
laura ihren namen hat sie schon vor
jahren geändert sie lebt was sie denkt
und versucht darin authentisch zu sein
ich bin nicht stark
ich bin mutig vielleicht versuche es
zumindest zu sein
das gelingt nicht immer ich bin
verletzlich und sensibel aber ich glaube
das macht mich nicht zu einer schlechten
aktivisten sondern zu einer besseren
empathie erzeugen und integrieren soll
ihr feminismus und doch keine
kompromisse machen
das ist ihr gerade in zeiten des
vormarsches der anti feministischen
rechten wichtiger denn je ich dachte
eigentlich ich werde mir jetzt zeit
nehmen einen roman zu schreiben
aber die fiktion muss warten es gibt
andere arbeit zu tun sehr viel arbeit
es sind beängstigende politische zeiten
und jeder mit einem guten gewissen muss
all seine fähigkeiten da einbringen und
was ich kann ist schreiben also werde
ich das tun sagt und macht sich auf in
den kampf und haut in die tasten
penny will mitmischen wo es drängt wo es
ihre stimme braucht aber vorher
vielleicht doch noch ein bisschen
weihnachten feiern